this is eliot van buskirk with wired com
here at South by Southwest where
hipsters from locations as varied as
silver lake los angeles and williamsburg
brooklyn have gathered to see the finest
the world has to offer in indie music
what are you guys looking forward to the
most this year honestly always big fan
of the after parties personally there
really late yeah you're not going to the
panels at eleven in the morning that I'd
say yeah this year the big themes are
fun people having fun this year it's not
as many dour guitar bands we're actually
seeing dance music seeing girls on stage
in boots singing crazy toons and making
a crowd go wild and the crowds really
are reacting more this year it's not
quite the standing in the corner
Wallflower crowd so we might have seen
in years past people are really getting
into it this year and of course they're
twittering about it everybody we've
talked to pretty much is doing something
with Twitter delhi two dublin we're
celtic punjabi electronica we're not one
of those bands that's a totally addicted
to twitter and on there like we'll
probably one tonight hey this is what we
did this what's going on we ran into one
band who had never heard of it but might
have been pulling our leg we're not sure
so are you guys doing any like any of
this twittering of shows and all this
other technological stuff where you came
in a pretty old school with the seeds
you got a lot of fans on Twitter well I
just got on there so I'm trying to build
it up I'd be on the road so much so you
know I mean so what are you guys
civilians are gonna band here in a band
we're called a good fight we're from
Fayetteville Arkansas are you tweeting
about it you guys like use Twitter to
give users weird here before
like three days ago as a matter of fact
you know twit you know Twitter right now
they don't know to you that he hasn't
heard of Twitter it's like this way of
blogging 140 characters you know like a
facebook update or something and so not
doing that keeping it old school or if
I'm tacoma washington and yeah we're
gonna tell Sophie yeah another fan right
there yeah there you have it this year
at South by Southwest it's all about the
Twitter it's all about the bands but
most of all people are having fun this
year it's all about the fun I'll catch
you later I'm gonna ride into the sunset
yeah
you